well welcome to what promises to be a
compact with stimulating discussion of
one of the tough challenges for peace
and security today the Saltzman
Institute's devoted to examining
problems of war and passed the peace and
devising strategies from the first to
the second and over the past year we've
presented a series of conferences and
panel discussions by experts on security
issues in the Middle East and especially
Afghanistan I think this evidence is
obviously appropriate because
Afghanistan is the most pressing
challenge for at least four American
national security policy but also
because it seems to me it's the most
vexing a few months ago I took advantage
of an opportunity to go to Afghanistan
for a short time all too short because I
lacked confidence in any potential
solution to the problem that I could
think of and sadly I'm ashamed to say
that despite a bunch of informative
briefings in the country meetings with
nato and afghan officials visits the
trainers forces and Special Operations
units in the field and frank exchange
over dinner with General Allen I have to
confess that I came away about is unsure
about what should be done as when I
started an embarrassing admission for
someone's supposed to be an expert on
national security policy but a
reflection at least I think of the
complexity and fearsomeness of the
challenges and options but the the menu
here from now are much more experts on
Afghanistan and I could hope to be so I
hope that will come away today with some
better insights one of the panels
originally built for the event Tom Gregg
has been forced to withdraw at the last
minute but fortunately we have an
equally well qualified observer to
replace him David Rhoda our moderator
Scott Smith will now introduce the
speakers and get them going
thank you let me say a few words of
introduction i think that the one
possible answer to the question of
endgame in Afghanistan is uh you know
what already ten years is a long time
the siege of Troy lasted ten years
Vietnam War lasted ten years but I
always thought in Afghanistan if you
look at the last millennia of history
and pull out three common threads you
have historically in always weak state
historically and always strong society
and historically a great resistance to
outside influence and what are we trying
to do we're trying to build a strong
state we're trying to weaken or change
society and we're trying to do it with
increasing amounts of foreign assistance
this I think will take more than 10
years so this will be one of the
questions I think our panelists will
will deal with should we be the end game
right now but we most definitely are the
end game and I remember at the Lisbon
summit when I was with the United
Nations back in 2010 and is one of these
meetings where you have 40 or 50 heads
of state around a large table President
Karzai at the center and president
Sarkozy of France you know leaning over
the table and telling President Karzai
you know mr. Karthus was when the whole
idea of transition was being was being
discussed in st. President Karzai you
know we're here to tell you and to
guarantee you the transition is not
about ending our involvement in
Afghanistan transition is about changing
the nature of our involvement right now
it seems very much to be about ending
the involvement and the idea of
transition instead of entering a new
phase where assistance is more civilian
than military seems to be more
characterized by words like exit
strategy or more unshared oliva perhaps
more accurately a rush to the exit and
certainly despite all of the disclaimers
by policymakers now that does seem to be
the tone of the discussion in certainly
in the in the media that I like this
title endgame it's a it's a phrase that
comes from chess and chest like
Afghanistan is a very calm
get your game but the end game of chess
is the part where enough pieces have
been reduced that there's a certain
amount of clarity on the board and there
are even objective moves that are ideal
and they're not good so when you read
the commentary of chess masters on other
games you know you have excellent move
or big blunder and when chess masters
play themselves when they reached that
point of the endgame sometimes looking
ten moves ahead they decide this is you
know I can't possibly win you know I
offer a draw or I withdraw that is
certainly not the case in Afghanistan
and let me read briefly a paragraph i
think is from a recent paper by hamish
nixon and carolyn hard sell that sort of
sums up the much more complicated
chessboard that we have in Afghanistan
they write the conflict in Afghanistan
as a confluence of intersecting regional
and internal conflict structures linking
the post 2001 war on terror with
regional tensions internal historical
rivalries legacies of past conflicts
governance weakness and war aid and drug
economies however and this religion via
however it should be and on top of it
the balance of these factors is changing
over time altering the complexion of the
conflict as quickly as efforts to
resolve it are introduced so we're it at
an end game in terms of time certainly
not an end game in terms of seeing what
the pieces are and what the ideal moves
should be fortunately here today we have
two grand masters of the Afghanistan
chess board um David road is gladly
agreed to a replaced on Greg who
couldn't make it because I spoke to him
last night and he said he had to pull an
all-nighter for the paper whose deadline
was moved up so just because you leave
school doesn't mean you stop doing all
nighters uh but as the New York Times
South Asia bureau chief between
2002-2004 David was very much present
and covering the opening moves of this
conflict I think will be interesting to
see how he sees how that's evolved
especially compared to the objectives we
had at the at the at the beginning and
in 2008 he was part of New York Times
team the won a Pulitzer for his coverage
or Afghanistan and Pakistan you have
much more detailed bios of both of our
speakers so i won't go into to leave it
at that for for David
and I'm addressed for those who follow
this conflict needs no introduction but
I did want to recount you know a little
bit of an anecdote because every time i
hear i'm in Russians name i feel that
sort of twinge of regret because it
reminds me of perhaps the biggest
mistake I ever made and that was a
between my first and second year at seat
by went to Afghanistan to do some
research and I was working for an NGO
I'd worked with previously and while i
was in Kabul I met another American who
was there doing research on his own
thesis on the Mujahideen and he said
listen you know why don't you stick
around in Kabul for a few more months I
have good contacts with the Taliban in
the talmage just come into power and you
know stay a few months I'll introduce
you to them maybe you could write a book
about the Taliban and I thought you know
I have my things in storage of the
international house I have the semester
coming up how do I explain this to the
deans and and and anyway you know who
would read a book about the Taliban so
for all of you a you know the first year
students who were about to go off if you
get an opportunity like that don't worry
about the storage policies international
house I think I think with the royalties
that Ahmed has earned on that book you
could prolly by the international house
stand with that just a few comments on
on on format we have to stick precisely
to the time so we'll end this at 12 and
I'll have to be brutal about that as a
moderator I think we've agreed that I
med will speak first for about 30
minutes and then David then we'll open
it to questions david has to leave at
about eleven forty so if you have those
you have questions in particular for him
we'll try to uh privilege those with
that then I guess I'll hand over to uh I
mean you're welcome just to stay seated
yeah ah can I stay damn um I love your
energy about the Greek war I usually
talk about you know this is the longest
war the US has ever fought and this is
World War 1 in world war two combined
but of course the Greek energy is very
good because all we now need is a wooden
horse you know
to take the city I am this war and get
the American troops out well you know I
I'm gonna try and divide my you know
talking in three parts and talk about
three crises that are faced in
Afghanistan there's an international
crisis a regional Crisis and a domestic
crisis the international crisis is
fairly obvious everybody wants to get
out there's a global recession there's
no money to really continue support it
in Afghanistan despite all the promises
made the Afghans are not expecting big
potatoes once the Western forces leave
and the Obama came in promising an end
to bolt was is and he certainly you know
wants to complete this full-out you
Europeans or even more eager the French
in fact to pulling out next year and
that could lead to a snowball effect
amongst other European powers with
smaller forces so there is a very
serious international crisis in terms of
will the money beer available post-2014
for Afghanistan will the commitment of
the whole international community be
there not just you know Special Forces
US Special Forces you know living in
some secret camping in northern
Afghanistan waiting to swoop down or
al-qaeda but a real kind of commitment
for continued training of the forces of
the Afghan forces etc now the regional
Crisis is even worse I mean when a
president obama came in he took the
suggestions or many people which was
that afghanistan needed a regional
solution and it needed they needed to be
a regional compact for non-interference
and Afghanistan now the reason for that
is that Afghanistan has six neighbors
all of them have been brutal in
interfering inside of Ghana Stan backing
one warlord against another etc you read
the history of the 1990s in the Civil
War it is all about who
backing room and it was every single
country including the near neighbors who
are Saudi Arabia India and Russia were
also involved and so with the six direct
neighbors so and the Afghans are loathe
you know this kind of interference now
because of course everybody's been
interfering there since 1979 they are
deeply suspicious of their neighbors and
so this idea of appointing Hallbrook as
the AfPak sort of guy who would get her
out and formulate some kind of regional
agreement has really fallen flat flat on
his face because first of all you have
this huge build-up of tensions with Iran
it was pretty bad even then but there
was a hope there was a slight hope that
perhaps the US administration could talk
to Iran separately on Afghanistan as it
did in 2001 when bond took place not get
Iran involved I mean not talk to you Ron
about the bigger problem that the US has
but of course that is all gone out of
the window because of the nuclear issue
and and it's it's impossible now for
this administration to actually have any
kind of secret private off-the-record
dialogue with Iran because the
Republicans would hammer them the
Israelis would hammer them etc etc and
anyway now it's pursuing this part of
sanctions it doesn't want to let up on
it by giving any concession so in that
sense Afghanistan is really i mean i've
really been worked over because you know
iran is a crucial player iran is a
crucial economic player it supports it's
always supported the the Shia minority
in afghanistan and the other minorities
and it is being left out and the other
country that is really precarious right
now is pakistan the u.s. of course was
in alliance with pakistan but right now
as we see you know we've had five months
of no relationship now in the last
couple of days i hope that there will be
some kind of relationship although that
still has to be worked out but things
are very bad between the u.s. and
and the idea that Pakistan would provide
an open exit for US troops to leave and
all their equipment and also help out
with talks with the Taliban and rain in
the Taliban fighters and akane zand
other people I mean all that for the
time being seems to be on hold so two of
the biggest neighbors of all are not
involved in the regional thing and and
as I said the regional the idea of a
regional agreement is looking in
considerable disarray you might have
read that in the last couple of days
Putin has supported the idea of American
troops exiting through north through the
northern what is called a northern
distribution network that's you know
that's a major concession that the
Russians are giving but they want to see
NATO get out of Afghanistan as soon as
possible they don't like NATO but the
problem of exiting through the north is
that is hugely expensive it's not
convenient at all especially when you've
got things like artillery and tanks and
heavy vehicles and you know all the rest
of it so there you know so the regional
issue is really intimately tied up with
several practical issues you know to
actual the practical practical of
withdrawal I mean how are you going to
withdraw with all these troops and and
things you need Karachi you need
Pakistan for that but it's going to be
very difficult and and you need
relationships with Iran particular I'd
with Pakistan so as to prevent
sabotaging the peace process or the
talks process which I'll get into a bit
later and and and then of course there's
a long-term stability that you want for
Afghanistan in the region which is also
a regional issue in other words you you
would ideally like pipelines and
electricity and oil and gas flowing down
from Central Asia across Afghanistan
into energy deficient South Asia and I
knew you would like peace on this so
that Afghanistan could earn money
through being a
did you know a pipeline transit location
as well as get energy for itself and
they're all sorts in a mineral
development in Afghanistan is a huge
possibility but for that to you need
regional guarantees regional security
because those minerals have to get out
of Afghanistan and this is a landlocked
country etc so even if you look at the
future the regional equation is
incredibly important and at the moment
we are nowhere near it the third issue
is the domestic situation inside of God
has done the most interesting proposal
that I've been supporting for quite some
time is that they're going to be
elections in 2014 for the presidential
elections cuz I has to step down because
he's done two terms of in office already
and that's he he's got a term limit I
hope he does step down but more than
that yesterday he made the statement
saying that he's considering which is
something I think a lot of people are
quite keen on that bringing the
elections forward by 1 year 2 2013 next
year in fact that would solve several
problems because the idea of having an
election and a political transition in
Kabul the same year as you're
withdrawing the troops and possibly
those numbers of troops won't be
available to protect the elections to
protect the United Nations the
monitoring etc oh and and and the
foreign troops preoccupied with their
own withdraw this would create a lot of
problems so the idea of bringing it
forward you have your political
transition under the auspices of the
foreign troops you set up a new
president and you cabinet you bring in a
whole lot of new faces I think that
would do enormous amount to restore
confidence in the Afghan people and in
the international community because of
all the problems that you're having with
Karzai and
you know etc so that's the first thing
the second issue that I find very
disturbing is that is the huge growth in
ethnic unrest in Afghanistan in 10 years
partly this has been fueled by the talks
with the Taliban because the as you know
the Taliban a Pashtun the government is
also Pashtun and the non pashtoon see
these talks with the Taliban is a very
grave threat to them they don't want the
Taliban back in any shape or form and
what has being talked about is it
possible you know power-sharing deal etc
between cars on the Taliban or between
the government and the Taliban so that's
one reason but I mean there are other
reasons that there's enormous continues
to be enormous suspicion of Pashtuns and
the Taliban the Taliban have now
penetrated into the north of the country
in a population which is largely non
Pashtun Uzbek Tajik azzara and and the
north is very nervous about this and
it's created a sort of ethnic dimension
the other issue is the the whole uneven
development in Afghanistan because the
Americans and NATO have plans so much
money into the south and the east where
the insurgency is taking place billions
of dollars of God into so-called
development and winning hearts and minds
which have not been very successful
frankly and hardly you know one tenth of
that money has not been spent in the
north etc and the north of actors kind
of fend for themselves in many ways
getting help from Central Asian
countries getting energy from there
cutting their own deals with neighboring
states so you had a kind of uneven
development which has again excessive
painted the ethnic divide and and and
the third issue is that the secure I
mean there many issues but I mean one of
the other last issue is that I'll talk
about is the ethnic divide in the
military the us astray is training
350,000 police and soldiers
they want to reduce it in in a year or
two perhaps by a hundred thousand to
about two thirty thousand but
nevertheless the death traditionally and
historically Afghan armies have been led
by the Pashtuns they've been largely the
officer class has been passed tuned and
the the bulk of the soldiery has been
Pashtun now because of professionals are
linked with the Taliban and there's an
enormous reluctance of Pi students to
volunteer for the army you have a
preponderance of non pas students the
office are going particularly high and
mid-level is mostly tajuk and a and a
lot of the recruitment is obviously
coming from the minorities and you have
very few Pashtuns being recruited from
the south a little more from these for
very few from the south bathrooms are
being recruited but they're the wrong
kind of questions you want questions
from the south from the insurgency hit
areas and then you want / students from
the East which is traditionally provided
the officer corps and the soldiery and
and I'm neither question and so this is
exacerbated because you've got now tajuk
afghan units you know or mixed units but
predominantly tajuk going into Pashtun
areas and and this is creating you know
a lot of resentment etc you know for the
question so the ethnic / let me just
touch on the economy I'm not going to go
into this briefly but I think one of the
biggest mistakes us has made is it is
failed to build up an indigenous economy
the tens of thousands of afghans who
work for the foreign forces are all
going to be rendered jobless in the next
18 months what the hell do they do where
do they go and and this and this and you
know I mean particular these this class
of Afghans is precisely the children of
911 these are the kids who you know
learnt English studied you know worked
with foreigners I believe in democracy
support you know women's rights etc etc
and either these are precisely the guys
who are going to be rendered jobless
and they will be either you know they'll
they'll try and leave I mean you know
these are your technically these are
your technocrats I've gone technocrats
who would stay on and I know how
organizations function the institution's
function but you know there's not going
to be much of an incentive economic wise
and there's a limit to how many people
the government itself will be able to
absorb from them and and for me this is
a real crisis and there is not an
indigenous economy because unfortunately
so much of the investments has been sort
of hearts and minds for temporary you
know to curtailing the influence of the
Taliban there has not been long term
investment in the economy now the
chances in five or ten years if peace
comes is very good in the sense you know
the mineral development we talked about
the Afghanistan is a transit sort of hot
point for you know pipelines etc but
that is way into the future what happens
in the first sort of three to five to
seven years of the transition
economically speaking the other
consequence of this is going to be of
course that whatever gains have been
made to curtail poppy production through
massive kind of subsidies to farmers and
all that kind of money is not going to
be available anymore and a lot of these
farmers are going to go back to poppy
production simply because you know
they're does not be in that kind of
long-term investment in new crops new
high high value crops which people could
sell and the kind of infrastructure
where you know they can you know
freezing and canning and all that kind
of thing where they could actually keep
their crops and sell them at a at a
higher price etc so people are going to
go back to a poppy now finally the other
really big issue on the domestic scene
here are the talks with the Taliban and
this is really what I want to get into
as you know these the Americans have
been talking to the Taliban for the last
nine months or so yeah this was a
situation brokered by the Germans and
Qatar over a period of about two years
and there have been several meetings and
certainly one of the primary issues here
was that both sides needed to show some
confidence with each other so you leave
it confidence-building measures you know
early on in the game and there's been
discussion about opening a Taliban
office in Qatar where the Taliban it
would be a not a representative office
of political office where talks could be
held you know round the clock as it were
and other Afghan group civil society
women cetera could come and meet with
the Taliban and get you know the Taliban
would kind of get exposure to these
people and all the rest of it and and
but the opening of the office has got
interminably bogged down because another
confidence-building measure which was a
proposed earlier by the Taliban and
initially agreed upon by the Americans
was the exchange of five Taliban
prisoners in Guantanamo in exchange for
one American who was being held and that
is being bogged down for the last four
or five months and in fact right now the
Taliban have suspended the talks and we
don't know when they will resume now
there are two three problems here the
first is that these talks were set up
with no preconditions in other words
whatever state you know the Taliban
would not expect you to make statements
of intent that we respect the
Constitution or the President or
anything like that and no but the
Americans expect you to make any pre
conditional statements there is now
demand from many people in Congress and
from people in the military that the
Taliban actually make a statement of
distancing themselves from al Qaeda at
all written well that that is something
that they've done in their literature
already you know and and this is one of
the issues that that has bogged down and
the second issue is mean that simply
there is a division in the
administration which is quite strong
there's an element you know certainly
you know the State Department the White
House want these talks to move forward
as quickly as possible I DoD and
probably the CIA are dragging their feet
one issue is that people are very sad I
mean obviously the DoD and others are
extremely sensitive about Guantanamo
releasing anyone from Guantanamo like
this could set precedents you know etc
now this is very tragic when you think
about it that the first paper that obama
signed was the paper to finish
guantanamo and we've still got
Guantanamo and it's still a bloody
headache because you you know the whole
the talks with the Taliban are revolving
around Guantanamo and Guantanamo is
something that you know you have not
been able to resolve and it's it's it's
international law I mean the whole issue
of Guantanamo is having an impact on you
know tomorrow it may have an impact on
you know trying to curb the Talib the al
Qaeda and Yemen or Somalia or somewhere
because you've got you're still holding
prisoners from all these places so
Guantanamo is a is is is a huge issue
the second issue is this this kind of
belief frankly that is being still
predominance in the US military that we
are winning we're winning what there is
no military victory in sight there's no
way you can defeat the Taliban
physically on the ground eliminate every
single Pashtun who's fighting for the
Taliban because if there are 15 million
mushrooms in Afghanistan they're 40
million in Pakistan and there's no
shortage of them you know pashtuns
coming into you know and and they're
only have you know hundred thousand
troops there of the of American troops
so this is a bit disproportionate you
know so my this idea that somehow you
you fight to the last minute of 2014 and
then you would draw
then you leave the Afghan troops to
carry on the fight and they will stand
there staunchly and carry on the fight i
think is really absurd because I don't
see the Afghan army being in a position
to carry on the fight that the way you
are and if there's no sign of a
political solution then the Taliban will
be I think for they are not right now
wanting to take extreme measures such as
you know wanting to capture the country
or capture Kabul they know their own
weaknesses now they know they can't do
that but certainly if there's no door
left open for them to enter into some
kind of negotiated settlement then of
course they will take extreme measures
and then you of course the Americans
will then turn around and say or we told
you so you know they're complete
bastards I mean look they want to
capture Kabul they wanna get but I mean
if you don't leave a door open for them
now while you know while there is still
time before 2014 it's going to be tragic
not to speak of the Afghan people now I
think I think it's terribly important
that now the third factor in in in in
this deadlock is the election campaign I
think it's very clear that in a by in
about six to eight weeks if nothing
happens if these deadlocked talks are
not resumed by the americans in taliban
and there's no breakthrough on this on
this confidence-building measure about
the prisoner exchange we are going to be
then by May or June in an election
campaign and there's no way the
President Obama is going to be releasing
anyone from Guantanamo to be clobbered
by the Republicans you know in between
june and november so essentially if
nothing happens now we could be talking
about these talks being dead locked
until early next year which would be
tragic in my opinion because you would
completely lose the confidence of the
Taliban you would lose the confidence of
Pakistan you would new lose the
confidence of a lot of European partners
who are very anxious that these talks
conclude
in NATO you and and you know I think
you'd be you'd be losing the confidence
of people involved in the process now
who would be utterly fed up to have to
wait nine or ten months before this
process resumed knowing fully well that
you know how are you going to explain to
the Taliban actually look you know we've
got an election campaign I'm sorry but
we can't do anything now because our
election campaign Trump's you and peace
in Afghanistan I think that's a very
difficult you know sell for the Taliban
it is a very difficult by for the
Taliban so this is the third problem you
know associated with these strokes huh
and finally there's a problem of
Pakistan now as you know Pakistan is
harbard all these Taliban leadership for
the last ten years and the irony is that
i think what parks are expected was that
at the end of its you know at the end of
this period when the end game began you
know Pakistan will go to the Americans
and say haha we brought the you know
we've got the card that you need or that
you want which is the Taliban and if you
want to talk to the Taliban you come to
us you sit with us and we are part of
the equation we will sit at the table
and you know and and we will also
extract our founder flesh of what
exactly we want in Afghanistan what we
want with neighboring India what we want
from you and and the ironic thing is
that it is it is as we enter the endgame
the whole relationship with Pakistan is
broken down partly the fault of the
Americans partly the fault of the
Pakistanis and and no one side wants to
admit that you know that that they're at
fault now even if the relationship
resumes which I think it will in the
next few weeks it will be at a much
lower key than before and certainly if
the u.s. is them going to go to box and
say look I'm sorry but we've got an
election coming up and we can't really
talk to the Taliban anymore and we don't
really we're not going to ask for your
help in
anything at least for the six next nine
months that's going to be enough another
terrible down for the whole region
because box on the military may well
presume that this is the moment when we
should continue back the Taliban and
step up military activity and I'm let
the Taliban kill more Americans you know
and let them prove leaner let's make
this even costlier for the Americans if
they don't want to talk so this is the
whole dilemma lastly I'm often asked you
know why the Taliban would want to talk
look I think I think the Taliban have
learned in number of lessons from the
past they they knew that they were
hopeless a government they had lost the
support of the people by 2001
Afghanistan was starving it was a wreck
they had kicked out the UN they kicked
out everybody the NGOs everyone because
of you know the influence of bin Laden
and the and they know that there's no
trust either by the international
community or by the Afghan population in
their ability to run the country so for
them not and they know also that if they
were to try even attempt to recover the
country the international community will
run away and they would run away with
the money there would be no aid for
Afghanistan so better to work out some
kind of power sharing agreement with the
existing government which has a face
that at least we'll still get foreign
money you know if it's cuz I or the next
guy whoever it is so for them it's still
better to you know work with someone who
can at least have a you know extract
money from abroad and not like I've
gotta sign into a basket case once again
I think the other thing is that yes they
are exhaustive I think they want to get
out of Pakistan shadow I think they
realize fully that they can't come and
more than that that they can't recover
the north like they didn't during the
Civil War they cannot refight you know
re fight that war if you remember
between 96
the 90 and 2000 they fought a very
bloody civil war to conquer the country
basically now this time the north is
prepared the non Pashtuns are prepared
their arm they'll get support from india
from iran from other countries and and
it would be a much blood year civil war
and I think the Taliban are just tired
and they want to go home from Pakistan
and they want some kind of peace if
there is no as I said is if no window is
allowed is open for them to enter into
some kind of dialogue with the
government before 2014 then I feel the
worst for Afghanistan Pakistan in the
whole region as well as US policy in
that region thank you very much well I'm
do David thank you Scott I first one say
I'm not a Grand Master of any form
whether it's chess or involving Central
Asia and Achmed is the Grand Master I
was informed yesterday that I would have
to be giving this presentation with ola
giving a 30-minute presentation and then
be after Ahmed Rashid speaks you can
imagine my fright I will not probably go
for the full 30 minutes I want to keep
this short and let you know you ask
questions particularly of him and and
I'll take questions too but let's be
honest and I'm sorry I have to leave
early I actually teach a journalism
class up at Brown University where I
went and I long ago had set up a trip
where my students are coming down to New
York today and I'm meeting them at my
office at Reuters at noon so I apologize
for having to leave early I roughly
speaking you know agree with what Achmed
has said I think we've all failed the
United States has failed i think that
afghan government has failed Karzai and
I particularly the Pakistani military as
well has failed and then we can talk
about that more in the QA just you know
again in terms of the current currency
situation and you've probably seen this
in news reports and Scott mentioned I
was in Kabul when it fell in 2001 there
really was tremendous hope and I think
Ockman will agree with me there there
was a real opportunity and I covered the
war in Bosnia earlier in my career and I
all I will I will we have failed we
should leave the question is how we
should leave but I am convinced we
missed an opportunity that there really
was an opportunity and and there was a
tendency in the Balkans to blame ancient
ethnic hatreds that these are just you
know barbaric people who want to fight
each other forever you you hear some of
that you know it's it's expressed much
more politely about Afghanistan now
because the US wants to leave again we
should leave it's gone terribly but we
all missed an opportunity Afghans were
eager for a new Afghanistan eager to
resolve their own ethnic differences and
that has not happened in the last decade
and we're all responsible for it you
know the numbers are terrible 3,000
civilians died last year there's 30,000
asylum applications filed by Afghans
this is mostly this this 911 the
children of 911 that I fed referred to
very skilled and you know Afghan
moderates who want to be part of the
world many of you have probably been
there but it's you know the cities are
so different from the villages I have
found and you know young Afghans at
least many the ones i've talked to sort
of you know want to be and across the
region or sort of looking for a third
way they don't want to be ruled by the
taliban and sort of forced to pray at
gunpoint five days a week they also
don't want to be ruled by americans with
guns either and they're you know had
this dream of something different you
know a sort of following a rough example
of you know Dubai or turkey or Indonesia
and in terms of what will you know
what's in terms of the lack of
confidence the current estimates are
that at least this is the officially
declared amounts of money that's fleeing
the country
this is people just taking money out in
suitcases was 4.6 billion dollars last
year that's the equivalent of the entire
afghan national budget 4.6 billion
that's the declared money estimates are
that twice that amount is actually
flowing out of the country so things are
falling apart rapidly I wrote a piece a
few weeks ago about the war I'm going to
sort of run through or do an expanded
version of that piece some of the points
that are pretty basic particularly
compared to what aqua had to say but I
regret a few of the phrases in here but
so to stand by the basic arguments and
it was written more for an American
audience you know I sort of the title is
five myths about the Afghan war and
again it's simplistic in places but you
know these are my sort of rough thoughts
on the myths and then and then what we
should do one thing that sort of
frustrated me with me is that you know
there's a real view in particular on the
American Left that you know just
Afghanistan and the region doesn't
matter at all and we should just get out
what interest do we have there we have
none whatsoever and I would argue that
we do have a interest i mean there's
obviously humanitarian one and an
ethical one in terms of you know we have
had thousands tens of thousands of
afghans working with us for the last ten
years and we are essentially going to
abandon them and they will face I think
harsh retribution from hardline Taliban
that's a sort of ethical argument
obviously there's been real gains for
women that will disappear and then the
real hard-nosed argument for Americans
to be blunt is Pakistan which hawkman
referred to this is sort of very crass
to say but Pakistan has you know dozens
of nuclear warheads if Afghanistan
becomes unstable or the Taliban take
over large parts of Afghanistan I
believe that the hardline Afghan Taliban
will work with the Pakistani Taliban and
you will then have a growing Taliban
threat in Pakistan as well I see I from
personal experience I was kidnapped by
the Taliban and held in the tribal areas
for seven months I saw that the ass
pakistani taliban work hand in hand and
i think that there you know there are
elements that want to negotiate and when
we should you know negotiate with those
elements but this is a very serious
threat to both Afghanistan and Pakistan
and you know imagine you know again to
be crass what would happen to oil prices
if the Taliban were somehow to seize
control of a military base in Pakistan
and get hold of the nuclear weapon
that's a worst-case scenario but I'm as
worried about Pakistan's long-term
stability as I am about Afghanistan's
long-term stability things have simply
gotten you know worse each year I think
the Pakistani army is over confident
about its ability to handle the Taliban
they've lost control of the Pakistani
Taliban and it's sort of a Frankenstein
that you know the US helped create in
the 80s Pakistan nurtured through the
90s and it's it's a very dangerous
situation so that's why the region is
important another sort of assumption
among Americans is that all Afghans want
American forces to leave immediately
absolutely all Afghans want American
forces to leave and the message I here
and this is you know my bias would be
this is from the sort of again the the
educated urban class you know they don't
want Americans leave immediately there
actually angry at the idea the United
States will simply walk out of the
country they want the u.s. to have a
political settlement that somehow has a
chance of stabilizing the country they
want Afghan security forces to be funded
and immediate and hey see withdrawal you
know they at least this that group of
Afghans see that as an additional
betrayal they want a sort of very
planned withdrawal and not that the u.s.
just just sort of runs for the exits and
I'm afraid that that's that's what we're
doing I think if there is an immediate
withdrawal there's an assumption in the
u.s. that an immediate withdrawal will
just bring peace to Afghanistan all the
flooding will stop I disagree with that
Achmed you know can and should talk
about this Michael's simple who's also
he's also he's been an advocate for a
long time of talks with the Taliban
he says that any further acceleration of
the US withdrawal will actually reduce
the chances for a peace agreement and it
actually increases the chances of a
civil war meaning you know again the
u.s. heads for the exit everybody just
sort of braces for another Civil War and
and it's it's it's important that we do
this very methodically and slowly a
fourth assumption about our myth about
the region that all Taliban a rabid
fundamentalist uninterested in
compromise aqua has just talked about
that I generally agree with him I think
that they are seriously interested in
talks they do know there are limits in
terms of running the country and being
part of the international community and
I think we absolutely should pursue
talks and and and force a divide in the
Taliban see if there are moderates who
will compromise and those who won't it's
definitely worth pursuing and then
another and a sort of fifth myth would
be that and this was sort of right at
the height on after the horrific
massacre happened outside of Qandahar
that there was talking the press of
obama accelerating the withdrawal of US
troops immediately like starting this
year and i think it's a myth that
accelerating the withdrawal is smart
election-year politics for obama let's
be frank that's what sort of driving
everything is a selection that window
has passed i don't think they're even
talking about it now but at the time i
was arguing you know it's bad for him
politically to be you know leaving
afghanistan and a panic it's a clear
military defeat and that's not going to
look good for him an election year I'm
all of this argues for some kind of
settlement and a much more orderly
withdrawal I then sort of try to talk
about what you know what should the u.s.
do and it's an incredibly difficult
situation you know one point was to sort
of hold steady meaning stick to the 2014
plans don't break from them continue the
talks with the Taliban there's clearly
fears in the White House that if they
negotiate with the Taliban or make any
deals if these prisoners are released
from want
Oh it'll become an election year issue
and it will it will hurt them I think
they have to continue the talks even
though it's an election year there was
just a news report now that there's the
agreement on night raids and the
transfer of prisoners to the Afghan
government Admiral McRaven who's the
commander of US Special Forces as
there's talk of the strategic agreement
with the Afghans this would be a 10-year
agreement of us troop presence and
civilian assistance one number that came
out just this week was about roughly
6,000 US Special Forces staying this is
a plan the military's developing that
they haven't presented the White House
yet it's different than the Biden plan
Biden has talked about having American
special forces sit on isolated bases and
only venture outside to carry out raids
what McRaven and the military is
proposing is that about 4,000 of the
6,000 Special Forces be you know working
alongside Afghan units in the field with
them there would still be bases like the
one outside Qandahar and pond Joey
unfortunately where this terrible
massacre occurred and the military seems
to favor having US troops out in the
field partnering more with the Afghans
Biden's idea is that they they're sort
of sitting on these bases I've always
seen Biden's ideas sort of unworkable
it's sort of a fantasy that they'll be
this small number of American soldiers
sitting safely on bases while out in the
Afghan countryside its sheer chaos with
warlords preying on people the Taliban
preying on people why are people going
to give you know the US forces
intelligence for raids or even cooperate
with them if they're just sitting in
these bunkers essentially the total
number of US troops that would be 6,000
Special Forces but there's been reports
of you know anywhere from there will be
several thousand regular soldiers to
sort of help with intelligence and
logistics and other things and then a
very large American air component and
the idea would be that with these
special forces units combined with
Afghan units they would help them with
communications calling an air support
when they need in intelligence the idea
being at least among the US military
that they're not going to completely
abandon the Afghans the problem of
course is cost we're currently spending
I think seven billion dollars a year on
the creation of these very large Afghan
security forces roughly 350,000 as
Achmed mentioned the number will
probably come down to about four billion
with a u.s. paying about 2.5 and hoping
that NATO and the Afghan government will
pay the rest that's a staggering amount
of money I argue though that we should
be spending billions in Afghanistan for
several more years in part because of
the insane amount of money we've already
spent there we're currently spending a
hundred and thirty billion and this is
sort of part of a broader argument about
you know having a diplomatic settlement
continuing to fund the Afghan government
security forces and continuing civilian
aid we cannot abandon Afghanistan if
there is a political agreement its reach
we've got to continue supporting the
country that is a carrot I think for the
Taliban and it's we will be it's a it's
a wise investment for the United States
to continue sending money they're simply
a banning the country would be a
disaster last couple points I made in
this piece was to go ahead with this
transfer of Taliban prisoners that the
administration should take this risk I
think more Americans are instant in the
u.s. leaving Afghanistan and not a
chaotic Afghanistan and so an agreement
is worthwhile and the transfer of
prisoners from Guantanamo is worthwhile
and I would I don't know how you do this
and this is definitely a question for
for Achmed is um you know how do you get
the Pakistani military to go along with
a deal as I said earlier I believe that
the Pakistani policy of sheltering
Afghan Taliban is a you know to me it's
been a disastrous policy for them it's
created tremendous anger in the United
States in Washington there's huge
distrust of Pakistan obviously the bin
Laden raid sort of sealed that and you
know I hear from American officials this
real frustration with you
now if the if the Pakistani army wants
to shelter these militants and believes
they can control them then you know they
can deal with them in the future 3000
Pakistani soldiers have died fighting
the Taliban you know thousands of
Pakistani civilians have died in
suicides attacks from the Pakistani
Taliban and it just um it's just to me a
tremendous disservice to Pakistan the
game the ISI has played and continues to
play where they think they can control
militancy there are problems and this
I'll just sort of wrap up I agree that
moving forward the elections would be
extremely helpful these are sort of
questions also for Achmed isn't in a
sense Karzai has talked about leaving
office there's rumors that one of his
brothers would run which i think you
know obviously that solves nothing and
maybe elections won't matter because
this sort of elite that's been enriched
through the primarily the US contracts
for supplying the American military will
continue to to be in command will that
make a difference if there is an
election the ethnic divide that Achmed
mentioned in Afghan forces is a huge
problem it is you know a tajuk and
hazara dominated force when they come
into the south it's it's a disaster most
of the troops don't speak Pashto and
they're seen essentially as foreigners
you know and I don't think there's a
military solution i agree with him it
gets back to the need for a political
settlement and i also agree that we
failed to build an economy i'm working
on a book about the sort of civilian
effort since nine eleven and what a
disaster frankly it was and to me it was
as important as the military effort but
we focused you know so much of our
activities on the american military
you've heard the number we spent at
least 1.2 trillion dollars in
afghanistan and pakistan since 2001
ninety-five percent of that money
ninety-five percent went to the
deployment of american forces
that leaves sixty eight billion though
that did go to the State Department and
other civilian agencies and you know the
sense is that we looked for short-term
solutions we're going to build a hundred
schools in a year you know NGOs can't
handle that large a project in such a
short time so much of the money went to
contractors there was very little effort
to build up Afghan capacity it was all
about American priorities USA Dean the
show that it's meant the money quickly
creating metrics that would impress
members of Congress and we've gotten you
know virtually or very very little from
that 68 billion and my book is an effort
to you know look at what went wrong on
the civilian side and try to and this
may sound naive you know look for a new
way to engage the region it's not so
military based somewhere between this
massive you know these massive military
efforts and complete abandonment we
can't disengage entirely from the Middle
East I know people are excited about
fracking here but we're going to be
buying oil from the region for decades
to come we are intertwined in it and
it's a fantasy if we think if we just
pull out our forces we're somehow not a
huge player in the region you know we're
giving billions of dollars to the Saudis
and oil money and we need to I think and
find a new way to interact in the region
and you know it's a tragedy what's
happened in Afghanistan and it's the
young Afghans that sort of haunt me the
most I was recently in Tunisia and it's
you know I asked them what they want
from the US and it's sort of similar to
what at least I heard fry hear from
young Afghans and Pakistanis was that
they they sort of obviously don't want
military interventions but they want
investment you know they there they love
technology they want to be part of the
world economy they want educational
opportunities and they don't want sort
of loans and charity and traditional aid
and we have to rethink the way we
interact you know and we use our aid
that it's not some charity where we come
in and build a well and feel very good
about what we've
but instead we come in and and and and
facilitate local businesses and and and
help the economies grow again that's
naive and pie in the sky but we have to
do better I think and it's it's a
tragedy what's happened in the last
decade Thanks thank you um normally it's
the privilege of a moderator to ask the
first questions but I'm willing to
forego that if their questions right now
and maybe I'll add some things later on
yeah hello my name is Ron Tyrathca I
teach politics at Amherst College and
i'ma an alumnus of sepa from too long
ago I think it would help a lot of us in
the in the analysis of this to hear more
about the Taliban themselves who exactly
are the Taliban besides saying they're
Pashtun what are they what are the
points of tension between them keeping
keeping how how unified are they as an
organization and as a command structure
keeping a movement together in any
situation like this is is difficult and
it's been a long time how so the
question is could we hear more about the
Taliban and the Haqqanis inside
themselves as a movement how how solid
are they and what of what are the
possibilities of their breaking up or or
outside forces kind of splitting them up
let me then also abuse the moderators
privilege and add to that question for
either of you how also how important are
al-qaeda now we know that one of the red
lines of the negotiation has been that
the Taliban have to break with al-qaeda
we also know that al Qaeda has been sort
of dispersed around the world they don't
have the influence that they used to
have in Afghanistan is is that a red
line or a condition that still makes
much sense in terms of the
it's supposed to be happening oh that's
not I think you you've been the most
recently and you've lived amongst the
most recent like that's again that's not
fair um I will speak very briefly about
the counties but you have to answer the
broader question about the moment I
spent seven months in North and South
Waziristan I was kidnapped with two
Afghan colleagues Anna one of whom saved
my life we managed to escape largely due
to his bravery and so my bias when I
talk about not abandoning the Afghans
and these these hopeful young Afghans
it's it's him that I think of I was not
allowed out of the house very often but
alright and I but I was now and then
anyway my Afghan colleagues were Arabs
and Jews becks particular news Beck's
walked the streets of Miran Shah North
Waziristan every day they are sheltered
by the hakan II network there was an
Uzbek militant who acted as a teacher to
my guards on how to make roadside bombs
to any taught Afghan and Pakistani
Taliban to make bombs that would kill
Pakistani soldiers Afghan soldiers and
American soldiers so there are
foreigners that are very active in that
area and and many of them so and there's
very intense in close personal issues
between the hakan ease and these
foreigners I think though that and and
that they would be loyal to a decision
by mullah omar they are looking Tom
Gregg who couldn't be here knows this
quite well because he spent a lot of
time in eastern Afghanistan looking for
a political settlement they want i think
positions in host pack tia and pack
tikka and you know I you know I again
this is why I think you negotiate and
you put them in the difficult situation
of deciding what are they going to do
you know if they are have this
possibility of a settlement Afghanistan
will
they walk away from some of these
foreign militants you know I don't I
don't know or they were you or maybe
this is split within them the other
reality of the economy is the last thing
I'll say you know and obviously I'm
biased but most people would agree you
know they are in many ways a criminal
organization masquerading as a pious
religious movement they are more brutal
I think are known as I think the most
brutal Taliban faction they've used
kidnapping as a way to raise money for
years they have you know killed you know
and beheaded dozens of tribal elders in
eastern Afghanistan who refused to obey
them and you know there's a large
segment of Afghans that don't want to
see them coming back because they've
been so brutal so it's a very
complicated mix but they're also lastly
the most effective group the big attacks
you see in Kabul the attack on the US
Embassy was carried out by the Haqqanis
they're very effective you know and have
the safe haven we bumped into a
Pakistani army convoy when I was being
driven in one location and the driver of
the car was battered in Hakone he's the
younger brother of Suraj Akane who runs
the Hakone network and I thought when we
saw this Pakistani army convoy coming
near us that this was this was this oh
my gosh you know this is it the
Pakistani soldiers will discover us and
we'll go free and instead the car in
front of us pulled over to the side of
the road as soon as I saw the Pakistani
army convoy and then Badr didn't pulled
our car over to the side of the road and
the Pakistani soldiers one of them got
out was very nervous I mean they really
are afraid of the Taliban pointed an RPG
at the vehicles and then the all the
people got out of the car in front of us
and badruddin only got out of our car
and I was kind of confused and then the
Pakistani soldier got back in his truck
and the convoy drove towards us and
instead of stopping or trying to inspect
anything was happening the Pakistani
soldiers just drove by and badruddin
Akane actually waved at the Pakistani
soldiers and smiled at them
and after they got back in I was he got
back in the car I was sort of crushed
and he said we have an agreement with
the Pakistani army where the civilians
the civilian car in front of us all
civilians have to get out of the car
when the Pakistani army approaches but
if it's a Taliban car only the driver
has to get out that allows them to sort
of move prisoners around or you know
shelter foreign militants and there was
no effort whatsoever by the Pakistani
military that I ever saw in seven months
to confront the Taliban on the ground
they simply stayed in their bases so
very close ties and you know Achmed can
talk about maybe the ISI will the quota
sure agree to a deal and Kenny is I
deliver the Haqqanis look there's no
doubt that this whole insurgency of
bacta Taliban post 2003 when it began it
was aided and abetted enormously by
al-qaeda Taliban commanders went to Iraq
to learn what was the tactics being used
there by al-qaeda they came back with
all this IEDs and high technology and
all the rest of it so and they've used
alcohol is inside Afghanistan they've
used Central Asians and all sorts of
other foreigners so there's no question
that that has been a very close
relationship now I think I think what
the Taliban are now suggesting is that
they want to break that both at the
political level and at the support level
and and and not take any further support
from them but you know as I said earlier
this can't be a precondition this is not
something that Taliban are going to do
overnight right at the beginning of our
dialogue process I think the process of
negotiations they will slowly do that
and at the end of the negotiations they
will give a commitment you know to break
with them now of course there's no
guarantee but I mean that's that's the
way that you know certainly I see the
scenario and a number of Taliban release
retired Taliban you I speak to that's
how they see the scenario that
Dave hadn't symbiote very close
relationship with bin Laden i'm an al
qaeda for the last 16 17 years and and
this is not something that can can be
broken up on the they are also very
scared and this also goes true for the
ISI that any break of relations with any
of these former actors the ice I al
Qaeda the Central Asian groups the
Chechens whatever that can lead to these
groups sabotaging any dialogue process
in other words assassinating Taliban
negotiators massacring their families
you know kidnapping their brothers and
sisters or their families because don't
forget I mean this peace negotiation is
going to be fraught with enormous
difficulties within the the opposition
movement the guerrilla movement and and
and we should not underestimate the
threats that the Taliban negotiators
face for example there in the last few
months there was there's been enormous
pressure on the ice I to allow the
families of the negotiators who are
sitting in Qatar to be removed from
Pakistan and come to Qatar and some
families have been allowed to come but
that shows how scared the negotiators
are that their families are very
vulnerable in sitting in Pakistan either
because the ice I might kill them or
because our guide i might kill them or
because somebody else might kill so you
know you are you you have to look at all
these these issues I think I i think the
ice I believe that it controls the
Taliban a to over to a very large extent
and that it can kind of deliver the
Taliban if and when relations with
America or ever improve I think that's
largely probably false I don't see I
think the Taliban have moved away
considerably from the ice ice control
they are fed up with the ice I one of
their first criticisms with almost any
interlocutor that they meet with is to
not criticize the American occupation of
their country but to criticize the parks
Johnny micromanagement of their politics
so I think you know that that is an
enormously a very different trend from
four or five years ago not that they
don't appreciate the support that
they've given Pakistan has given them
but I think they're fed up with this
micro management and you know and don't
forget you see from from their point of
view they accuse Karzai of being a
stooge of the Americans so cuz I and the
other Afghan government people accuse
them of being a student of pasta and
that's something that an Afghan doesn't
want to hear I mean an Afghan is an
Afghan you know honorable upright tribes
were proud etc etc the last thing an
Afghan will tolerate will be called the
Stooges somebody else so for the Taliban
they have to come they want to come out
of the shadow of being this you know in
having this dependency syndrome on
Pakistan and and and and I'd break with
that you know and I think Pakistan is
under a lot of misconceptions regarding
its so-called control I mean we saw in
two thousand just before nine eleven
then essentially parks on had lost
control of the Taliban completely they
blew up the Buddha as you remember they
almost kicked out the UN they did all
sorts of things with the with the NGOs
something that box on didn't want them
to do but they went ahead and did it so
that relationship could break down you
know again in a in a very similar way
and but as far as the Pakistani Taliban
is concerned I'm what makes me very sad
that if these talks don't take off a
peace agreement or some kind of
ceasefire in Afghanistan between the
Americans and the Taliban and a peace
agreement between cars and the Taliban
would have a hugely positive impact on
the war in Pakistan and all the
Pakistani Taliban I think it would it
would it would negate their their resort
date which is you know we are conducting
jihad against this infidel American
occupation of Afghanistan and we are
killing Pakistani soldiers because you
know they are they this is
little jars the American Pakistani
soldiers are the you know are in bed
with the with the US military so that's
why we attack Pakistani soldiers now all
that would go out of the window if there
was a peace deal and and ideologically
speaking politically speaking the Python
Taliban would be left with very little
reason to continue their war so um that
would be another spin-off of these talks
which I think would be hugely positive
for Pakistan I'm a tarp r kelly from the
politics department of the new school I
have two questions for both of you one I
wanted to push back a little on the idea
that the American military thinks that
they can win in Afghanistan my senses
they want to be done with it and go and
think about the air and naval conflict
with China um but there's not a lot of
people left to think that there's going
to be either a military or a state
building solution in Afghanistan so I
wondered what may be your your reactions
are your views on with what the US
military have to say second question is
a State Building question there seem to
have been some success at the provincial
level in setting up Afghan security and
political institutions and I'm wondering
how firm are the links between places
like Helmand shayaris my British
colleagues call it and kebbel know what
what can stand without the Western
presence in terms of an Afghan security
presence in in the provinces he wants to
go in prison I can do helmet
about the military well look I don't
think either of us said that the US
wants a military victory at that the US
military want a military victory I mean
I didn't say that's at me and I know you
know day that's not what I'm saying that
the u.s. well if she believes in for
some reason or the other they seem to be
thinking that they can deliver not
military victory or military success but
they can deliver sufficient blows to the
Taliban before 2014 if they keep
fighting until the last minute until
2014 so that it will make the there will
be less of a war that the Afghan army
will have to fight now what I'm saying
is that you know simply that that to me
is not a feasible strategy I agree with
you I think they have dropped the idea
of victory I think they know very well
that they can't win this war they want
to get out but on their timetable they
don't want to be pushed into as David
said you know the 2013 timetable or any
other time table and you know I mean in
destroy if they supported the talks
process there would be a mutual
symbiosis between state and defense
because look the presence of US troops
and the fact that US has got pressure
there is vital for the talks process and
you kind of talks when you moved out you
can't say okay now we'll talk we moved
all our troops I'll we have no we have
no stake in Afghanistan where no
pressuring of that now will talk to you
so it's a good thing you've got troops
there and but what I'm saying is that
those troops have to be used in a
political way now and they have to be
used for a political raise or gate not
for a military raise all day because the
military raised on day is over yeah you
can kill more Taliban you can decimate
you can kill another 10,000 Taliban
24,000 will come from Pakistan so what
are you gonna do you know so I mean
that's my argument that I don't see the
military is having a real game plan
whereby the talks are included with
military pressure you know unfortunately
I think military pressure is important
they should be diet of 2014 and this
intervening period should be used for
dialogue
there's a the current governor of
Helmand you probably know this is glob
mongaul who was a guy that the British
insisted come in there you know the
quick answer is if the money from Kabul
dries up he's done I mean hellmann's a
sort of not fair example because the
poppy crop just distorts everything and
Taliban you know there's the and to be
fair since the American surge started
security has vastly improved in Helmand
poppy cultivation is down when you
blanket you know I believe there's
20,000 American marines in Helmand now
in 10,000 British it has improved thing
in the Helmand River Valley and sort of
the central towns there and Afghans that
live there say it's improved but there's
just no follow up there the Afghan
security forces aren't strong enough to
hold it themselves and you know the
broader State Building effort failed i
would say it failed initially in Helmand
and it's a microcosm of the country
because the initial governor that Karzai
appointed was hugely corrupt involved in
the poppy trade and when there was this
window in the sort of hopes in o2 and o3
you know for you know you had you know
basically this criminal running the
province and the first the United States
deployed a hundred and twenty-five
troops in Helmand for the first three
years of the American effort and
essentially you know they were primarily
Special Forces and they let the the
local governor run it the same thing in
in Qandahar with gulag Esper's I so in
short we failed but we didn't try very
hard and we sort of missed the window
when it existed early on
hi I'm I'm a second year super student
here I just wanted to kind of pursue
this idea of a presidential election in
2013 a little bit more um kind of if
this deadline was brought up or if this
um this day was brought up politically
who would it benefit and you believe
that kind of a an alternative to Karzai
and maybe other political structures
that have been in place would be able to
develop in time and do you think we can
meet their kind of logistical challenges
within that within a year or year and a
half well you know I I mean that makes
opinions about this i'm told by I've
gods that the the the elections can't be
brought forward by yeah but clearly if
their political decision is made that
you know it will happen and and the NATO
troops will obviously help I think you
know later us will be able to guarantee
much greater security in 2013 than they
would be in 2014 when everybody thinking
about leaving you know and all the
equipment has left the country or is
about to whatever and and I think it
would be of huge benefit to have a fresh
face a new cabinet a new bunch of people
to deal with the aftermath of the
American withdrawal and with the Taliban
also now I think what issue in this
election would be would you be able to
get talks moving with the Taliban so
that they could actually participate in
these elections in some form or shape or
the other would they agree to would they
sabotage it what would be the Taliban
position what could the government and
the Americans do to assuage the Taliban
if these elections were brought forward
so that they did not undermine them I
mean these are all very big
imponderables you know the assumption is
that if there is a big know if there's a
peace deal with the Taliban and a
ceasefire and then there's sort of
negotiations for power sharing you would
need some kind of Loya Jirga or
something to validate a a new new piece
a power-sharing agreement and how would
that fit in with the elections I mean
all these are you know important
questions but I think overall
overarching everything would be the idea
of a new government and a new faith
which would perhaps inspire more
confidence in the Afghans and cuz I can
at the present let me just interject
that uh on on Tuesday I made wizard em
talk in Washington where he proposed
this idea moving the elections up to
2013 and on Thursday cars I gave an
interview saying that perhaps the
elections up to 2013 so uh perhaps
dealing with some powerful voices here
I'm each also note that another
interesting development on elections is
that the former interior minister jalali
has announced that he would run in 2014
which not too many people have picked up
on but which i think is a fairly decent
sign because one of the problems that
you have is it afghans are faced between
on the one hand Karzai possibly
continuing either through his brother or
a state of emergency or some kind of
rigged constitutional amendment or the
abyss which is what happens after 2014
it's the end of the term it's the end of
the international presence nobody knows
you know what follows the idea of having
another candidate who also has requested
was a fairly good reputation as a not
that corrupt Minister of Interior is I
think a date opens a new sort of your
possibility that it's not either Karzai
and its successor or the abyss there's
actually a doctor use a determinate
third way but there is another political
current that people can begin to get
behind
thanks Alex Cooley Barnard College on
the salzmann is student question for
mebut David be interested in your
thoughts too it's about this
regionalization issue that you discussed
and I was wondering if you could unpack
this a little bit more on how you come
down on it was the administration right
to pour all these energies into a
regional model was the idea right and
the model wrong thinking we can model
this on Madrid and just conduct
intensive shuttle diplomacy or where
they're just you know structural
problems given the relationship with
Pakistan with Iran that made this sort
of a non-starter and if not
regionalization what what has this come
at the expense of that might have been a
more viable strategy Thanks well I think
what essentially went wrong was that
India was initially included in this
whole half pack you know Holbrook was
given the what-you-call-it mandate for
you know to deal with India as well and
to try and you know because back sounds
obsession with India and Pakistan's
obsession with India's role in
Afghanistan etc it was considered
critical to have India on board and to
try and foster some talks between India
and Pakistan on making their presence in
Afghanistan more transparent and what
happened was simply India refused fought
back and forced the Americans to drop
india as after as part of the AfPak sort
of triangle and of course that
completely deeply annoyed the back sons
and and kicked off the whole
administration's kicked off on the wrong
foot as far as far as the military was
concerned because the military said ah
but here we are typical America you know
they're they're kowtow to the Indians
India's the new Israel you know if
whatever israel says you know the
Americans do whatever India's says the
Americans do so there was a real lack of
cooperation and we'll unwillingness to
support a regional process which
allbrook was trying to run I think we
because of this India factor india
wasn't involved but i think i think you
know the other factor simply was that
not enough
um effort was put into it I mean you
really needed a full time negotiating
team to go from country to country to
country and brokenness and and it was
not the job of one man it was a job of
you know a lot of people a lot of
American diplomats should have been
involved in this it was a
multi-dimensional process because you
had to talk to people as from China to
Russia to you know South Asia Central
Asia the Middle East it is a huge
performance you know and and this could
not be done by a Dayton conference or
something like that it needed to be done
nitty-gritty meeting each country
individually signing out their problems
with the other country whatever it was
over the Afghanistan and then I'm then
trying to work out a sort of middle
ground and that effort really wasn't put
into it um I think the administration
made three mistakes in 2009 and it's
it's part of our system they also were
coming in the economy was in freefall a
lot on their plate I think and Scott
talked about this and if you can talk
about this more though the elections in
2009 were critical and you know there
was talk of maybe person I just
mentioned earlier gulag assures I
possibly running against Karzai I'm not
sure jalali would do that well there's a
suspicions of the Afghans who lived
abroad I'm sure you've heard this
they're called dog washers it's a
reference the theory is that they all
were that was their job when they lived
in America but there what and so the
u.s. is policy in the end and the
elections was this level playing field
approach where they sort of encouraged
everybody to run from za holy-o's on to
jalali and it every Afghan that was
talked to to Abdullah thought they were
the Americans chosen candidate in the
long story short there wasn't a my
understanding is there wasn't a clear
either strategy the administration had
towards the election or they just didn't
have the nerve to try to frankly
engineer Karzai's ouster and I think
that'd be that would have been very
difficult but there was sort of no clear
approach and cars I was sort of
mishandled as well
there's talks of these kind of blow ups
he had with Holbrook after the elections
I know that after those meetings cars
I'd demanded to speak on the phone these
were when they were trying to talk to
him about a runoff he demand to speak to
Hillary Clinton and to Obama and both
refused there was a again you know
they're coming after bush they want to
do the opposite of him it's a tendency
in every administration and there was a
sense that the bush had coddled Karzai
too much they were going to get tough on
him that backfired he felt isolated and
angry anyway so they made a mistake in
the election related thing Holbrook was
essentially undermined there was a lot
of infighting the administration Jim
Jones considered him an enemy there was
a opposition the White House to him even
leading any kind of diplomatic effort
like that that helped killer
regionalization and then the third
mistake I think was the deadline for
what troop withdrawal that was announced
at the moment you're carrying out your
surge whatever you think of the surge if
you're going to do one and you're trying
to use the soldiers to create pressure
for negotiations you don't announce that
you're leaving that was a tremendous
mistake I think it was an effort to sort
of you know you know deal with the
American political scene and say you
know I mean you either surge or down sir
if you don't try to do both and and you
know that deadline I think just really
undermine the pressure that might have
been brought to bear on the Taliban and
I think on on the Pakistani military
also just on the jalali point let me go
who knows how he'll do but the main
point isn't so much that he will
necessarily be a serious contender the
point is that there is no an alternative
and and it's a development from 2009 in
2009 as David mentioned you had several
prominent Afghans good dog washers and a
non dog washer you know who were meeting
in Dubai and trying to decide you know
who should be the one that runs and who
will get behind them and they couldn't
agree and as a result there was no
credible opponent to Karzai except for
Abdullah who frankly was not that
credible anyway I saw your hand push
great he said does anybody do you have a
question directly for David or because
you
you're in your final five minutes so if
anybody has a question sushi guys I'm a
super student now and thank you for
coming I kind of wanted to ask about
some of the social gains in terms of
human rights and there was an article in
The Washington Post a couple days ago
about this resurgent phenomenon of kind
of dancing boys I don't know if you guys
thought I've been kind of tamp down
under the Taliban but the government now
is kind of increasingly unwilling to
prosecute this kind of abuse and but on
the other hand you had mentioned kind of
gains women's rights and I was just kind
of wondering how real is this kind of
like social progress that people do talk
about for women and what could we expect
to happen under a tub and government
power-sharing deal I think there really
have been gains and the US government is
in a really poor job of explaining this
in terms of six million or four to six
million girls being in schools that had
not been in the past it was amazing
again this is my earlier experience
seeing you know these classrooms where
you'd have you know a twelve-year-old
girl in first grade sitting next to
these you know other students who were
half her size but she had been unable to
go to school and she really care she was
so sort of desperate for education it's
been a huge a huge success also was the
health care sector in Afghanistan life
expectancy is up maternal mortality
rates are way down one ish inspect of
that was that the health aide was
distributed all through NGOs not through
contractors it was funded more
consistently there was more long-term
planning that was actually a successful
development program and you know it's
hard to know but i think you know
women's gains in southern afghanistan
will be lost if the Taliban come back in
again at the top on is a very very broad
movement they're not all hardliners but
my guards were told and believed that
girls schools were built by Westerners
because that was where Americans were
teaching afghan girls to be prostitutes
other Afghans believe that schools were
being used to convert Afghans to
Christianity so that's why they were
blowing them up and unfortunately these
young guys believe these stories and you
know they you know I think there will be
a lot of losses and and I just there
really have been gains the economic
growth in the cities has been tremendous
a lot of its distorted because of its
foreign aid but you know they're there
have been you know hundreds of miles of
roads built it's not that absolutely
nothing was achieved and maybe the media
was too critical of not covering that
side of it enough what you know but
where where the US did fill with
security and I'm too little effort and
then a surge that with a deadline and as
long as the safe havens exist in
Pakistan there was no way to ever secure
the country thanks you have to uh we
thank you now for sure for being sorry
despite your protests to demonstrating
your brand mastery of Allah nothing so
thank you all very much push um sleep a
student here thank you so much for
joining us today I have two questions
the first one is that it's much sexier
to talk about negotiations with with the
Taliban I'm much less sexy to talk about
Afghan government reforms I think many
people have argued that there's it's
sort of a flip side to the same coin
that two things should happen at the
same time and that maybe this is the
time at the end of the Karzai
administration before moving forward to
make some serious governmental reforms
weathers political parties or maybe
getting rid of the first-past-the-post
system is there any chance that this
could happen before 2013-2014 and the
second question is sort of looking back
and is there any parallel with SF and
NATO you know us leaving Afghanistan and
sort of a parallel with the way the
British left and in a South Asian 1947
um you because of their own economic
woes in a sort of trying to slap
something together some agreement and
move
out as fast as I could is there any any
pair of other you know in an ideal world
of course I would support you I mean you
know I i hope the selection will be
conducted through political parties and
that kind of reform will come about
before these elections I have I think
one of the reasons with the failure of
the elections in the past and the crap
you know the corruption and the rat
rigging and all the rest of it was
partly a result of that now guns cannot
mature properly and they cannot cross
ethnic boundaries unless there are
proper political parties and Parliament
itself can't function properly without
political parties we've seen that also
we've seen two Parliament's really fail
to to elicit real credibility and also
real pressure on the government so but I
at the same time I have to say that I
mean you know it's not very likely that
major political reforms will happen I
don't think the Western pressure will be
there because they would be preoccupied
with you know leaving and I'm just
getting the election over as it were and
and unfortunately there's not enough
civil society in Afghanistan to force
this to force the pace of this i think
you know these comparisons between the
Americans leaving and you know the
British etcetera a bit you know I mean I
don't see the parallels I mean I still
go I don't see the Americans leaving
like they left Vietnam you know hanging
from the skids of any copters or like
the British were defeated and one doctor
was left alive of the whole army you
know who arrived in Jalalabad no I mean
you know I mean we should remember that
you know ten years ago when the
Americans went into Afghanistan they
were welcomed by ninety-five percent of
the Afghans now you know what should
happen is we should understand and
analyze what happened in the meantime
why did that popularity go down the
tubes and why why was the Taliban
allowed to regenerate themselves why was
public opinion turned so much against
the Americans
what are the Americans do wrong etc etc
but you know again I think the colonial
experience is something you know
altogether different I mean there the
British were involved in Afghanistan for
a century and a half I've not in
occupation that they were involved at
least which is an awful long time the
American thing is still it's a long time
but it's only ten years but let me abuse
now my privileges moderator to ask you a
question that will give you also tries
to talk about your latest book Pakistan
on the brink you both.you both you and
David mentioned the importance of
Pakistan as well as what you've
described as strategic blunders you know
in academia we have this term of the
failed state which is where the
government no longer really controls
then there's a phenomena of the deep
state which is a state really run by
military establishment behind a veil of
civilian government and if I can
provocatively ask you know is Pakistan
becoming perhaps the first example of a
failed deep state that's right see um
well I I've tried to avoid this term
failed state or I've tried to explain
that Pakistan is not a failed state I
mean it has a functioning military it
has functioning institutions the mistake
has been that we you know Pakistan has
not been able to modernize itself it has
not been able to carry out post Cold War
reforms that almost every country in the
world did carry out it has not been able
to carry out economic or political
reforms it is and and and the cause of
this has been the fact that foreign
policy and national security have
impinged on everything else most states
have a foreign policy obviously all
states have a foreign policy which is a
reflection of domestic economy domestic
development domestic demands etc and
Pakistan has a foreign policy that
commands a you know domestic loyalty and
ultimately undermines and destroys
domestic development and that's what we
are seeing today we have a foreign
policy that is undermined the country
supporting militants in Afghanistan
okish me having a secret arm of
you know all these groups who are active
in Pakistan having an expansionist kind
of a foreign policy in the region all
these issues are undermining this the
state of boxer as a consequence of this
the elite is not interested in carrying
out the kind of economic reforms and
taxation raising more revenue land
reform all the things that we should
have done after the end of the Cold War
to make Pakistan more self-sufficient so
you know it's this is a stage in deep
crisis because it is it is very
difficult when you're under pressure
such as Pakistan is from America from
you know India from other to actually
turn the whole ship around and do a
u-turn and say you know now we have to
kind of stop arming fundamentalist what
do you do these fundamentalists I mean
you know this incident of office aid the
head of lashkar-e-taiba was just been
given a 10 million bounty by the US now
half the shades should have been dealt
with you know after 911 I mean this
party should have been put to bed and
and these these young people who belong
to it should have been d radicalized and
given new skills and re-educated and all
the rest of it you know after 911
because they use value after nine eleven
of a country a government supporting
Islamic extremist groups was zero now
you know Ben Laden it put an end to that
so unfortunately insist failure to to
reform so I you know I wouldn't say you
know it's not that there's been a total
institutional breakdown in Pakistan
which which is what I think a failed
state is if we look at Somalia other
some other countries we could be heading
that way there you know they could
splits could develop in the military you
know there could be a very serious
uprising by the Pakistani Taliban which
embraces the whole country and which
divides the military they're all kinds
of very scary scenarios out there um but
at the moment i think you know we're
still holding I must say I you know
there's another theory a lot of
Pakistanis have which is that we will
muddle through well you know we're past
the stage of muddling through
because as I said this the impingement
now of your national security policy is
so serious on undermining the state you
can't muddle through without major
changes let me though I think we'll make
this probably the last questions in
summit has a plane to catch to London
for the launching of his a book which
you should all by Elizabeth valcon year
and I teach at the Harriman Institute
here and could you tell us what the
Russian engagement has been in to what
extent they are now recently to what
extent are they helpful to us and to
what extent they pursue their own aims
and policies you know they're I mean the
Russian engagement in Afghanistan has
been very double-sided I you know
probably I would call it too faced and
they have been obsessed with and fearful
of the NATO presence in Afghanistan and
the US presence they feared that
especially these bases in Central Asia
that the US has would turn into
permanent basis and that the US would
somehow replace Russian influence in in
Central Asia well of course that hasn't
happened because these bases are pure
military bases in fact America has done
very little to help the Central Asian
states or to economically orbit or to
draw them out from the Russian orbit as
it were in fact I would say that in the
last ten years if anybody has gained
influence in Central Asia it's been the
Chinese who have come in in a very big
way economically investment and and
other things but on the other hand you
know the Russians also are very scared
of the Taliban they they hate the the
poppy production they are very they've
been quite supportive of the Americans
in fighting the Taliban and in poppy
products and in combating poppy
production and are constantly
criticizing the Americans for not doing
enough in in in cutting back on poppy
and after a lot of negotiations they've
agreed to this northern pipeline of
goods so that American US and NATO can
bring in their goods through the
caucuses in Central Asia and now there
is a deal being worked out or which is
almost work our liking for for US forces
to withdraw through Russia and Central
Asia which of course is much more
difficult because when you withdraw you
got all these thousands of vehicles and
thousands of heavy equipment and
containers and all the rest of it the
Americans obviously don't like that
because it's it's very expensive to do
this as compared to Karachi and using
box on but they are certainly Putin
seems to have given the go-ahead for
this just in the last few days and the
Americans seem to be preparing for this
so you know and and the Russians are
playing now of course it'll suit the
Russians for the Americans to move out
of Afghanistan but at the same time
they're very wary is true what they're
going you know what is going to be left
behind are the Taliban going just
threaten Central Asia is poppy
production going to suddenly overflow
and I'm swamp you know Russian cities
which it is doing already by the way so
again you notice it's this kind of truth
it's not a very clear policy or strategy
listen with that will offer you our
heartfelt thanks for for being here and
let you go on your way thank you also
for coming and for your excellent
questions if we do with some event like
this year from now given the fluidity of
the situation who knows what we'll be
discussing but this is I think extremely
rigid and lightning for all of us thank
you